hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es mal einen wunsch rezept
denn ganz viele meiner zuschauer fragen
mich ob ich denn nicht mal was veganes
backen würde also habe ich mich
inspirieren lassen und habe mich dazu
entschieden eine vegane torte zu backen
ich wollte sie inspiriert in der zeit
treffer war ein richtig tolles rezept
hat mich optisch total angesprochen und
daraus entstand ist diese torte und zwar
ist es einen objekt orte also aus dem
kühlschrank ohne backofen
da ist so ein richtig toller knusper
boden mit drin und eine schon fast sagen
die kommune im prinzip eine süße
guacamole nämlich eine avocado creme und
ja vegan das heißt komplett ohne
tierische produkte
das heißt mit komplett die vegane
komplett der armee man in der familie
grad krank ist nein also ok alles
sondern feierten probieren aus was ja
wir erinnern uns nicht vegan aber ich
wollte trotzdem mal ein rezept dazu
machen denn wirklich ich werde wirklich
ganz oft danach gefragt nicht nur was
das kochen betrifft sondern gerade auch
das backen weil beim backen ist eben
auch immer ziemlich schwer da
alternativen zu finden
aber ich finde in dieser dortmund ist
sehr gut getroffen und zeige ich euch
mal die zutaten sind gar nicht so viele
zutaten und vor allem sind jetzt keine
exotischen zutaten weil ich in der creme
mit nicht zum beispiel macadamia nüsse
ab wie in vielen anderen cremes die
vegan hergestellt werden sondern aber
carlos die man eben richtig gut bekommt
und die auch nicht zu teuer sind also
sag nicht immer pussi zutaten wird den
nova quoten brauche ich 60 g mandeln 30
gramm dinkel pops oder haare pops 100
gramm veganer weiße schokolade und für
die creme brauche ich einen beutel
akademie 200 milliliter wasser vier bio
limetten 100 gramm agaven dicksaft oder
zb ahornsirup 200 gramm soja joghurt
etwas meinl extrakt und vier avocados
ich stelle jetzt direkt mit dem boden
und nämlich sache die drei zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier bereits wasser
aufkochen lassen und habe den herd
wieder ausgestellt und habe jetzt ein
schälchen drin und wenn jetzt die weiße
schokolade im wasserbad schmelzen
es geht jetzt hier von alleine und kann
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
mandeln fein mahlen
das mache ich jetzt in den mixer und ihr
braucht es am ende einen mixer oder
einen guten pürierstab also auch für
später petri
ansonsten brauchen wir kein weiteres
küchenzubehör sie keine kühlmaschinen
kommen die man will da rein und werden
wie gesagt ganz auskuriert gemahnt
die schokolade ist geschmolzen und jetzt
kann ich die drei zutaten einfach
miteinander vermischen
jetzt noch die hv pops dazu die gibt es
eigentlich in jedem großen supermarkt
also da musst du einfach mal in der
mögliche abteilung schauen oder einfach
in der veganen abteilung und da gibt es
eben so dinkel parks oder the pops dann
müsste einfach mal schauen
wichtig ist nur dass sie umgesetzt sind
da ansonsten die torte wirklich zu süß
werden
jetzt würde ich die zutaten in eine
vorbereitete bakterien in tottenham auf
18 cm durchmesser eingestellt es wird
also eine kleine torte aber ihr könnt
natürlich die torte mit hilfe meiner
umrechnung stabile auf meinem blog de
können dass sie ganz einfach umrechnen
und zum beispiel auch eine 26 der torte
machen jetzt ein bisschen verstreichen
und dann fest drücken und zum fest
drücken nämlich jetzt ein glas und es
kann man vorher zum beispiel mit etwas
bald trennt spray einfetten bist ja auch
veganer
der boden ist verstrichen und muss fest
werden im kühlschrank
ihr könnt übrigens statt diesen dinkel
pops oder the pops auch beispielsweise
vegane konflikts nehmen wobei die
meisten sogar veganen sind weil sie
eigentlich nur aus mais und aus etwas
salz bestehen
die sollten aber auch unbedingt
umgesetzt sein also stelle das kurz in
den kühlschrank oder auch ins
gefrierfach bissfest ist und in der
zwischenzeit keine schon mal die creme
zu bereiten
damit die torte schön fest wird also die
creme braucht natürlich die akademie die
gebe ich jetzt mit kaltem wasser in
einen topf und früher so glatt und dann
stelle ich jetzt dem herd auf höchste
stufe und lacht die mischung für zwei
minuten sprudelnd kochen
die ak tine durfte wie gesagt jetzt zwei
minuten aufkochen und dann habe ich
jetzt dann herausgestellt und sie etwa
fünf minuten stehen lassen
jetzt kann ich in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die creme vorbereiten
neben dafür ist die avocados und
halbiert und dann nehme ich den kern
heraus und gibt das fruchtfleisch von
der abokarte in einen mixer
jetzt gemacht er abhebt limettenschale
mit rein da ist es ganz wichtig dass die
unbehandelt ist damit die schale auch
zum verzehr geeignet ist und ich hab
jetzt übrigens von der aok der drei
stücken um den event so riesig also bei
normal großen avocados kinder gerne vier
nehmen und bei so riese markaris am
besten nur 3
es ist richtig jedenfalls schon sehr gut
sehr zitrone limette limit up artist der
toll haben jetzt nämlich noch etwas
limettensaft und zwar brauche jetzt
nicht alles ich brauch jetzt davon 50
millilitern zwingen mäßig des baus oder
dürfte der saft von zwei limetten etwa
ausreichen
das verhindert jetzt auch natürlich dass
die avocados braun werden
stell dir am besten das mix gefäß auch
eine ware dann könnt ihr zuerst einmal
den limettensaft nämlich gut abmessen
und dann auch noch den agieren dicksaft
da finde ich nämlich immer ein bisschen
umständlich wenn man den vorher sich
abwägt als auch auf die waage stellen
und 100 gramm auf messen dann noch ein
spritzer vanille extrakt für den
geschmack und etwas so joghurt dann wird
das ganze jetzt gleich ganz gut durch
püriert und durch die avocados mit die
creme auch ganz toll cremig
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt eine ganz
dicke creme und wirklich total cremig
und da gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen was
mit zur kabine und für das jetzt schnell
dann verbindet sich das gute und gibt
dann eben auch keine klümpchen und dann
kann auch gleich der rest mir dazu
den mixer ding hat sich jetzt gar nicht
weiter aus denn da mache ich jetzt
gleich das musée drin
das heißt die avocado resse die wäre
dann auch nicht verschwendet oder ihr
könnt mir zum beispiel ein bisschen
veganer milch sojamilch und hafer
militär eingeben oder mandelmilch und
das noch mal mit so namhaften milchshake
richtig gut
jetzt nehme ich den boden der ist schon
schön kalt ich hatte es für etwa 15
minuten im gefrierschrank und jetzt
kommt da anteil der creme ryan dunn
verstreiche ich das ein bisschen
und geht es jeden die mitte noch ein
paar früchte und zwar wie ich jetzt hier
blau werben johannesberg und himbeeren
die sind jetzt bereits gewaschen und die
handelsbeziehungen stengel runter und
dann kann man die jetzt noch darin
verteilen
und dann nur noch mit der restlichen
creme bedecken sondern auch richtig
tolle farben und die creme ist schön
glatt streichen und dann muss die torte
nochmal in den kühlschrank für
mindestens 4 stunden
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel für
zwei stunden ein film oder auch länger
ein frieden und das ganze als eistorte
servieren
die torte des öls und jetzt werde ich
sie vom torten rahmen lesen und der
morath wartet schon ganz gespannt
so werde ich gesagt natürlich ganz
gespannt
egal ob also wie gesagt man hätte jetzt
auch einfrieren können damals eine
eistorte was natürlich auch
wahrscheinlich sehr lecker wäre nur ein
bisschen mit einer palette viele jobs
streichen
die nehmen wir übrigens gleich mit
zugriff oder komische legalität zu grill
wir können ja nicht nur gemüse also die
torte könnte jetzt so lassen kann
probiert verwehren es ist eigentlich
linie als süße guacamole und
ja ich bestimmt gesund wirklich
geschmeckt nichts anderes erwartet so
ich setzte jetzt aber erstmal auf eine
trocken platte schwickert anders man gut
den boden kann man im prinzip ja aus
verschiedenen zutaten machen jetzt erst
mal um kurz konzentrieren
es können also ganz gut machen weil der
boden eben fest ist durch die weiße
schokolade geschmack ich würde ganz
anderes also ganz los als also nicht
dass jetzt negativ ist ich finde es und
jetzt nehmt ihr noch ein paar früchte
eurer wahl am besten die die ja auch
schon in der torte habt und könnt jetzt
damit die torte richtig schön dekorieren
also ich finde das macht die dort auch
noch mal richtig aus das macht sie so
richtig sommerlich
durch die torte fertig dekoriert und ich
gebe jetzt noch ein bisschen süßen
schnee oben drauf und zwar seit dieser
extra feine puderzucker der nicht
schmilzt das heißt er bleibt jetzt auch
gleich auf der oberfläche
das kennt ihr vielleicht auch von
berlinern also von diesen köpfen daten
auch immer diesen süßen schnee oder eben
bei anderen geweckt aus der bäckerei
und freut sich jetzt schon ich von die
creme ein schlechtes muss jährlich im
waldgut vorkam ohne nur eben süß
schneidet einfach mal irgendwo an
es ist nicht einfach also ich bin auch
immer ne cola schmeckt nicola de cola
light schmeckt schon irgendwie nicht so
toll wie nach cola als ihr zustand
ob dieser kommen jetzt das neue cola
light wird oder ob es wirklich cool
schmecken die total ehrlich das darfst
du ob sein
ich finde ich ehrlich sein ja ich finde
man die torte einfährt kann man sie
besser schneiden und ich denke dass sie
mir sogar ein bisschen besser schmecken
entschuldigung ich nix passiert für die
tore schon jemand gestorben also hier
deine torte es tut mir jetzt echt leid
das stück jetzt halt nicht mehr so schön
okay ich habe lieber auf dem thema
sozusagen jetzt probiere ich kann man
hier oben er schmeckt hat adele ihm
heraus max schmidt ganz anders als
ähnliche negativen sinne
echt klasse ich finde mit kann man echte
überraschung sagen ich mache nur eine
vegane topleute werden wirklich
überrascht sein wenn es ja auch immer
also vor allem der knospen schmeckt sehr
gut oder sehr gut
in diesem hafen ist sehr super wirklich
genial jacobs kamera dann auch weiter
benutzen um zum beispiel müsli zu machen
also die schmecken auch in müslis super
liga ist auch gesund sein gesund und so
weiter vorsichtig also ich finde alles
in maßen ist gesund man hat es hier
natürlich keinen zucker mit drin wobei
wir agaven dicksaft arm oder vergessen
dass lagarde gesagt eben auch zucker ist
zwar kein raffinierter weißer zucker
aber trotzdem zucker ich denke die torte
ist besser und vielleicht gesünder als
andere trotten aber ich bin da wie
gesagt immer bisschen vorsichtig wobei
werden die weiße schokolade mit hin und
das mit sicherheit auch raffinierter
zukunft wird man hier auch sagen muss
würde jetzt erst finde ich nicht
schwedisches gala man von ihr 1 bis 5
und bringen die nur bis fünfmal
schwäbisch würde skala machen von 1 für
eine schwäbische star bereits bis 5 und
heinsberg günstig und 5er teuer wird
diese wahrscheinlich auch viele
plantagen sind richtig teuer
die vegane schuhe hat glaubt 60 gramm
zwei euro 20 hier kostet das ist schon
ein bisschen zucker ist auch wie
günstiger als diese agave dick sagt ja
was ganz anderes probiert 20 aus es
werden mit sicherheit über werte und
fand sich das recht gefallen hat würden
wir gerne noch neue kreationen für euch
machen dann denken wir uns ein paar
rezepte aus und begeistert euch damit
also ich würde euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss nicht so viel gemacht hat eine
coole fragt
über seinen hohen trage und eier sind
keine kohlehydrate natürlicher stoff zu
kommen alles drin
zu den kohlenhydraten ich gehe mal für
dich kurz auf wikipedia
m